[Music]
hey guys what's up we are going to do
something a little bit different today
and we would like to present the 11 most
powerful swarm aliens that can be seen
in movies and games yeah I guess the
definition of swarm
aliens deserve a minute or two maybe
just one minute as we really want to go
ahead with the list but before that do
hit the subscribe button for more videos
like these and there are more than 60
videos of our swimming this platform
right now so as by our own definition
swamp aliens are those extraterrestrial
species that can be seen in huge numbers
for one well that's no brainer but
sometimes alien species like the
Romulans or heck even humans of Stargate
are countless but that doesn't mean that
they are swarm aliens Independence Day
harvesters are also present in huge
numbers but they don't really count so
let's dive into another aspect of these
species their coordination and IQ swamp
aliens also share a common intelligence
like a hive mind or a collective
consciousness they are like ants and
most of the population are mindless or
single purposed armies that are
hell-bent on the expansion of the
species take the cinema for example they
all serve the queen or an empress and
can rapidly multiply which brings us to
the main point that defines them their
rate of reproduction or expanding their
population these aliens can be killed or
be brought to the brink of extinction
but a few moments later they are already
more in number than the human combatants
that often face them we know it's too
hard to rank them from the leaves to the
most powerful and so this will be more
like a random list and we'll let you do
your thing
so do command your rankings below so
without further ado let's get on with it
number one the cinemas from the Alien
franchise starting with the most famous
alien species the ones that actually
bear the name alien in the movies they
appear in we have the xenomorph this is
an extraterrestrial Endor parasitoid
species that possess multiple life
cycles like the egg the facehugger the
chestburster and the adult individual
they possibly originate from the planet
Proteus are also known as cinema of
prime one of the most deadliest of all
the alien species known these creatures
require a host organism in order to
reproduce hence being a parasitic swarm
species the appearance of the xenomorph
can vary depending on the host in which
the facehugger implants and on its life
stage hive cars age as well as a
varieties in which have been genetically
engineered by host species or
genetically grown these aliens can wipe
out a planet's population of animal life
in a matter of months
and at the same time creating more of
their own they are truly a swamp alien
species since they populate fast they
have a collective mind and appear in
large numbers during battle number two
the formics from the movie Ender's Game
these insect are and looking aliens
called formics were an advanced
spacefaring alien species and were
nicknamed buggers by humans due to their
insect-like appearance they consisted of
hive Queens male drones and workers
although their current caste system and
population is near extinction following
Endor successful destruction of their
overpopulated homeworld the formics
killed over 40 million humans during the
first invasion as well as second
invasion during the formic wars since
they believe that humans and other
animals that do not share a collective
mind were not sent in their failed
colonisation led to humans bowing and
ultimately successfully exacting
vengeance on these species the formics
appear to reproduce at a very fast rate
and their fighter crafts outnumber
humanity's drones by a hundred to one or
even more number three the arachnids
from the Starship Troopers franchise the
Burke's are also known as arachnids are
a hostile alien species that have
conquered many planets across space
originated from a star system called
Glenda thew which is on the opposite
side of the Milky Way galaxy their
collective Empire or infestations have
spread for thousands of light years
arachnids have millions of years of
evolution behind them and are in the
case of survival capability the perfect
species they have the ability to
colonize planets by hurling their spores
into space and possess a social
structure which fits their mental
capacities they have a very fast
reproductive rate and even though a
single warrior is more powerful than an
infantry soldier
they still had many times outnumber the
human mobile infantry in battle their
top tier which controls every brain buck
warrior and beetle is called the god
buck which therefore means that they
have a collective intelligence number
for the Necromorphs from the game dead
space the next aliens are an undead type
called the Necromorphs which are mutated
and reanimated corpses reshape into a
horrific new form by a recombinant
extraterrestrial infection or an alien
zombie virus if I may say so the
resulting creatures are extremely
aggressive and will attack any
uninfected organism on site the
Necromorphs are the main antagonists of
the dead space franchise and their main
and sole purpose is to acquire more
bodies to convert and spread infection
and create a brethren moon all
Necromorphs are extremely Hardy and
capable of surviving in lethal
environments such as the vacuum of space
this implies a total lack of respiration
or reliance upon a vascular activity
which explains the Necromorphs
resistance to wounds that would cause
massive blood loss due to hemorrhaging
in uninfected humans or other animals
number five the reapers from the game
mass effect the Reapers get out of here
that's what you might think but in fact
the Reapers are more of a swamp alien
like any other in this list the Reapers
are a highly advanced machine race of
synthetic organic starships from the
Mass Effect video game series these
Reapers reside in dark space
the vast mostly starless space between
galaxies and wait to return to beat the
living hell out of our organic BOTS
Reapers are capable of dominating the
minds of organic races through a process
called indoctrination and they can also
create a horde of armies by using the
organic species like us to produce
various biosynthetic trawls created by
using both living and dead organisms
fused with their technology so yes they
are a swarm alien species not to mention
that they appear in huge numbers number
6 the replicator from the Stargate
franchise this next entry is more like a
gray goo you know the unstoppable
self-replicating nanobots that is one of
the most feared and probable apocalyptic
events that we might face scary
so these replicators are an advanced
robots capable of reproducing themselves
indefinitely consuming all available
resources in an area to create more of
themselves originating from a planet
called Reiss world after the Creator the
human-form replicators of the Milky Way
galaxy bear resemblance to the bob of
Star Trek they are repair Queen they
seek out the most advanced technologies
adapt to repeated weapons fire and are
in general difficult to combat which
brings us to the next entry number 7 the
box of Star Trek franchise the BOK are a
fictional alien group which is not an
individual species like a few others on
this list they appear as recurring
antagonist in the Star Trek franchise
the Borg are cybernetic organisms which
are linked in a hive mind called the
collective the Box share technology and
knowledge of other alien species in the
collective through process called
assimilation to have a total number of
reaching trillions they forcibly
transform individual beings into drones
by injecting high-tech nanoprobes into
their bodies and surgically augmenting
them with cybernetic components
the box ultimate goal is achieving
perfection which eludes them no matter
how many species are linked to the hive
mind the origin of the box has never
made clear though they are portrayed as
having existed for hundreds of thousands
of years although they have a ball queen
she too is part of the collective number
eight deserts from the starcraft games
in this universe alongside the Protoss
and the Terrans which are an evolved
species of humans desert Stan as one of
the three dominant species of the Milky
Way and I universally feared hated and
hunted they are dedicated to the pursuit
of genetic perfection desert hardened
down and incorporate every strong and
advanced species across the galaxy
absorbing useful genetic codes into
their own the primal Zerg maintained the
genome of the Zerg species before the
creation of the Overmind after this they
were deviated from their primal
counterparts the swarm reduced their
physical appearance which means any
other strong species that are collected
into them they reject everything and
only include the essentials fighting
components they excel in proliferation
as per a high rate of reproduction
one-on-ones herbs are not as strong as
their Terran and Protoss counterparts
but desert are extremely resistant
chemical agents and other biological and
nuclear weapons and the numbers seem
like a renewable resource number nine
the flood from the Halo games one of the
deadliest swarms out there this entry
from the Halo universe is known as the
flood or the parasite as called by the
Covenant they are a species of highly
virulent parasitic organisms that can
reproduce and grow by consuming sentient
life-forms of sufficient biomass and
cognitive capabilities their spores are
like a disease and there is absolutely
no cure for their infection they were
first encountered in the Milky Way
galaxy by an ancient human Empire and
they were the cause of the forerunners
creating the halo rings in order to stop
these aliens to death by wiping out sent
in life in the galaxy they appear to
have as many forms as they are creatures
to infect they can consume entire
planets travel interstellar space and
create a grave mine which is the
ultimate form having a collective
conscience of all the biomass it absorbs
number ten the Turan is from Warhammer
40k the Terran is from Warhammer 40k are
an extra galactic composite species of
hideous in Sector Alien Swarm that is
actually a spacefaring ecosystem
comprised of innumerable different bio
forms which are all variations of the
same genetic makeup they seed planets
with their unrelenting armies and take
over civilizations in the blink of an
eye they are the ultimate predators and
to them all living things from the
lowliest insect to the most advanced are
faring aliens a mere pray these Tyranno
species are solely dedicated to its own
survivals propagation and evolutionary
advancement the Tyrannis collectively
form a monstrous super organism that
travel across the universe in their
great high fleets of biomechanical hive
ships they are similar to desert but on
a grander scale like a galactic level
threat descending from the void between
galaxies these swarms have different
fleets consisting of billions or
trillions but sharing the same goal
number 11 the octopus aliens from
skyline movies the cephalopod or octopus
aliens are the ones who created the
human race long ago as means to harvest
human brains in order to build their
warriors so after millions of years they
return to earth and begin their global
harvests using their brains to power
themselves up and building their army by
placing human brains into various
biomechanical structures these aliens
can rebuild their army in no time even
after a tactical nuclear strike on their
mothership seemingly killing off every
other drone only for them to reconstruct
and come back with a bang their caste
system consists of other drones and
other warrior castes and then the hive
mind who is the leader of the alien
forces who controls and coordinates all
the activities of the aliens on earth
ranging from harvesting to attacking
human settlements therefore the hive
mind is the actual alien in its pure
form so this brings us to the end of the
lists and do like share and subscribe
and also also do hit the notification
bell for regular and actual
notifications
[Music]